bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de pif
paf vous savez ces démissions on discute
de l'actualité ou la menthe perspectives
aux polémiques autour de l'actualité
avec beaucoup de sujets aujourd'hui on
parlera de sport vous avez peut-être vu
les mondiaux de cyclisme sur piste à
saint quentin en yvelines et bien on
reparlera de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
puisque le vélodrome notamment est au
centre des débats puisque peut-être qui
durera une candidature de paris pour les
jeux olympiques de 2024
on parlera aussi de ce qui s'est passé
au dîner du crif la polémique est ce que
ce sont en effet les musulmans qui sont
responsables de l'antisémitisme mais ce
que sont des français de souche comme
l'a dit le président de la république on
parlera aussi de l'actualité sociale
peut-être de ce que dit bernard tapie
après le l'arrêt de la cour d'appel qui
revient sur l'arbitrage qui lui était
favorable où il dit et la voilà on en
veut aux gens qui réussissent en france
pour parler de tout ça mustapha larbaoui
bonjour alors vous êtes je montre le
nouvel obs parce que quatre pages quatre
pages ne sont consacrés dans le nouvel
obs le titre liberté égalité foot
puisque vous êtes le président du club
de foot de trappes et cas parce qu'ils
sont formidables d'ailleurs sur vous sur
votre action sur ce que vous faites
parce qu'il formidable c'est surtout le
travail qui est fait sur le terrain mais
c'est vrai que l'article dans l'obs
quatre pages comme comme vous dites
reflète bien le travail et surtout
l'objet sur lequel on sait situer c'est
à dire que c'est un fois le foot est
ancrée dans des vraies valeurs qui sont
celles à la fois du football sans avoir
à les développer
mais en même temps les notions de
liberté d'égalité frater nouveau là mais
jouer 1
et puis vous avez mis je vous ai mis la
discipline pas beau c'est beau ce qu'il
dit c'est beau c'est une invention qui
semble la voie libre je vous n'avez pas
non pas de nouveaux livres n'ont proposé
dans votre maison d'édition cette
semaine mais pas dont vous n'ayez déjà
parlé mais des fois ça continue à se
vendre bien à côté d'où sephora mamani
vous maîtrisez bien vous êtes en
vacances comme étudiante mais vous
bossez avec nos pauvres et sur mon
mémoire voulait très bien et sur votre
mémoire aussi qui est consacrée à
l'adéquation de l'offre culturelle à à
ces publics spécifiques
à mon avis elle l'est pas mais bon
jean-luc madec pour jour poursuivent et
nous ça va bien dans les temps payé se
porter très très bien et on est tous
femmes femmes de mustapha sauf peut-être
en tournant vous là ya pas deux il n'y a
pas de page dans votre journal ben non
mais on a sorti un nouveau numéro
ce mois ci un nouveau numéro de
complément combler voir venir e4 que
j'ai oublié je vous montrerai la
prochaine fois avec grand plaisir et un
peut-être un petit point puisque vous
êtes
vous êtes d'enseignement de leurs
serviteurs mais aussi parfois dans votre
pharmacie a donc un petit point sur
cette épidémie de grippe
on est au cap des deux millions ont dit
qu'il y aura peut-être quatre millions
de personnes contaminées
il ya quand même eu près de 90 morts
donc c'est quelque chose de grave
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
on peut plus faire vacciner ça y est
c'est fini
alors certains disent qu'on peut
continuer à se faire vacciner c'est fini
après l'avoir la fin de feu dont ma part
je peux m'en part je dirais que c'est
pratiquement effectivement trop tard la
vaccination parce que c'est quand même
le seul remède sercel l'immunité qui
peut vraiment jouer un rôle dans les cas
de d'épidémie de grippe l'immunité et
auquel cas c'est la vaccination est là
on est efficace que dans 30 % des cas là
alors non ce que le virus a muté pendant
que mon voilà donc en fait c'est pas le
vaccin qui était inefficace c'est qu'en
fait l'action qui a été menée n'a pas
été la bonne c'est faire que le mlc
douter l'om est chaque année prévoit de
mettre 3 4 on va dire virus sauf que
cette année ils ont mis 3 et sur le h3n2
précisément il ya eu des mutations
sachant que ce sont des virus à arn qui
me groupe qui bouge beaucoup qui ont
beaucoup de voix là de deux capacités
quasiment de se tromper dans leur façon
de lutter et du coup c'est on est passé
à côté du virus qui a ce qui a sévi
cette année donc c'est pas le vaccin qui
parle qui est inefficace en soi
j'entends dans le principe d'un matériel
à peine dans la pratique et la souche
comme à muter en plus est ce que vous
êtes près de 90 morts est ce qu'il faut
paniquer si on attrape la grippe si on a
quelqu'un dans sa famille qui est
contaminée alors d'abord non je crois
que je crois que c'est pas utile de
paniquer patrice la grippe c'est
effectivement tous les ans que les gens
la contractent simplement il ya des
populations risquent donc on parle d'
immunité dans ce cas là donc c'est sûr
les personnes âgées quand une immunité
un peu faible en plus des maladies
chroniques donc des maladies qui sont on
au repas de la grippe ou l'homme a
directement maladie voilà je vais je
vais prendre un parallèle un peu fort
pour les spectateurs c'est le sida on
meurt pas du virus du sida
on meurt des maladies opportunistes en
l'occurrence ce sont des malades y
construire sa défense au moins forte les
défendre son point fort et puis il ya
une surinfection bactérienne fait le
virus d'ailleurs d'où le nom de grippe
on n'attrape pas la grippe le virus qui
s'agrippent il s'agrippe donc en fait on
a on a tout les tous les tissus qui
gonfle on a pratiquement une destruction
des muqueuses
auquel cas cela fièvre le rhume à des
écoulements nasaux et là dessus viennent
éventuellement se greffer des maladies
opportunistes donc bactérienne et là on
attrape des rhinopharyngites des choses
comme ça mais c'est pas la grippe donc
en fait c'est les personnes qui sont à
immunité fragile
le nourrisson par exemple pour les
personnes très âgées ou les personnes
avec des pathologies chroniques de type
diabète et surtout les problèmes
respiratoires avec l'asthme enfin toutes
ces maladies qui tourne autour de la
difficulté respiratoire
il explique qu'il ya des années où c'est
plus dur que d'autres c'est que le virus
est plus résistant c'est que le voilà on
l'a mal mal définie c'est encore une
fois les virus il y en a la structure du
virus pour faire simple c'est une plaque
d'immatriculation engrossé h1n1 on
assigne à rendre quatre combinaisons et
en fait on est globalement immunisés de
tout sauf que parfois il ya une
virulence particulière qui fait qu'on
est atteint alors après ça va dépendre
également de l'état de santé ça va
dépendre de l'état fragile de la
fragilisation du virus en revanche s'ils
avaient des choses simples à dire là
pour le coup pour les personnes en bonne
santé
si je me permets tu en bonne santé qui
attrape le virus de la grippe les autres
étant à haut à vacciner ou à prendre
beaucoup de précautions
c'est qu'en fait on pense pas souvent à
ça mais c'est un flou enza dont le
nombre une flandre c'est l' influence du
froid donc c'est le différentiel de
froid et chaud qu'on entend mais surtout
le taux d'hygrométrie donc on y pense
rarement pour moi ce que je préconise
tout simplement c'est qu'on est souvent
vos webcams à mâchouiller des bonbons la
bouche parce qu'en fait on ali muse qui
s'assèchent dans dans des plateaux comme
celui ci met souvent à la maison parce
qu'on chauffe dans les voitures on met
le chauffage dans les avions ou le taux
d'hygrométrie très faible cancon à des
muqueuses qui sont complètement asséché
et donc le différentiel de température
et le degré d'hygrométrie donc
l'humidité dans l'air est tellement
faible qu'on a une curieuse extrêmement
fragile le virus sa griffe facilement et
on enchaîne donc mâché bbh et prenez des
bonbons souvent dans nos choix ou une
écharpe ce qui permet de garder
l'humidité
en fait les choses qu'on a toujours
entendu dire bah ça s'est fait en bois
voilà le bon sens ou alors on rappelle
roselyne bachelot parce que
deux ou trois vaccins alors viens tu as
tout ce qu on a parlé tous de la grippe
aviaire que de la grippe saisonnière
était pas là bas est ce que quelqu'un
est allé aux championnats du monde à
saint quentin en yvelines
romain est magnifique mais les filles
par ben oui oui j'ai été épatée parce
que je trouvais ça un peu ringard avant
d'y mettre les pieds pour la première
fois je me suis dit on veut encore
dépenser des sommes astronomiques pour
un sport qui ont bien tout le monde est
en fait personne n'est pas très connu il
n'est pas très populaire le circuit et
contre toute attente s'était plein comme
un oeuf
mais le bâtiment est magnifique la piste
est sublime
l'ambiance était absolument
extraordinaire et puis on séchait
spectaculaire il ya des champions
français je veux dire tout le monde
jeunes ont scotché dans la performance
physique et extraordinaire de tous les
athlètes
on voit mieux de la piste en plus tous
les tous les acteurs tous les acteurs
des sportifs qui semble acquis sont
reines qui s'échauffent les mécaniciens
qui répare les vélos face était née une
expérience et un moment passionnant à
refaire faut surtout on aurait sûrement
alors on va sans doute reparler du
vélodrome
de saint quentin pour 2024 puisque la
paris serait prêt à poser sa candidature
aux jeux olympiques mais au baobab on va
peut-être voir quelques images de ses
championnats du monde qui se sont
déroulés la semaine dernière le groupe
de saint quentin
cinq titres sur 19 possibles et sept
podiums au total la france s'est
illustrée lors de ces mondiaux de
cyclisme poussé par son public elle a
atteint des sommets dès le premier jour
de compétition et l'épreuve de vitesse
par équipes
michael d'almeida grégory baugé et kévin
sireau médaille d'or devant les néo
zélandais est disqualifié pour un
passage de relais hors zone ça fait
depuis 2011 qu'on va aller chercher ce
titre
on tourne autour et la de surcroît être
à la maison avec un public comme il y
avait c'était vraiment satisfaisant
j'avais cru en 2006 aussi où il y avait
le même ambiance à bordeaux et la dette
à la maison sur nos petits entraînements
de tous les jours et de voir ce public
est de monter sa première marché s est
émouvant quoi c'est pas une fin en soi
mais presque donc voilà on va pas bouder
notre plaisir aujourd'hui les champions
du monde ont aimé on associe boom ayew
sur nos épaules pour en profiter les
mondiaux sont lancés et la france mis
sur orbite viennent par la suite les
titres de coquard est donné ce qui dans
la catégorie de l'américaine
et que dire de la victoire de grégory
baugé né à maisons laffitte l'illinois à
30 ans décroche un quatrième titre de
champion du monde de vitesse
une victoire particulière lui qui en
2011 avait perdu ce titre pour un
manquement au contrôle antidopage
c'est la première fois que tant de
personnes de ma famille sera champion du
monde donc très très très content très
émue j'ai revu florian rousseau aussi
qui commentait pour la télé arnaud
tournant
et des amis du sport aussi qui sont
venus
je pense à ladji doucouré leslie djhone
voilà non c'était très bien avoir un
événement comme ça chez nous je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de personnes qui vont
nous suivre jusqu'aux jeux olympiques
les tricolores qui engrange aussi deux
médailles de bronze avec julien morice
sur la poursuite et quentin lafargue sur
la vitesse si j'avais fait tournoi du
tessin international et enfin voila
c'est où
c'est un peu dingue et ouais je pense
que le fait d'être ici a beaucoup joué
maintenant ça me permet de croire en moi
encore plus pour les énerver
mais la star de ces mondiaux c'est cet
homme françois pervis le pistard n'est
plus qu'à un titre mondial du recordman
français daniel moreno
cette couronne dans les années 60 70
françois pervis nouvellement installée à
50 en libye mais qui a fait de ce
clairefontaine du cyclisme sa résidence
secondaire repart avec deux titres
supplémentaires
lui qui était à deux doigts de ne pas se
présenter vise maintenant les jeux
olympiques de 2016
voilà on progresse vous progressez bien
on s'aimera donc on a fait un très beau
championnat du monde et on a su montrer
à tout le monde que
on savait se savait talent jour j pour
les jeux olympiques on a vraiment pas
peur on n'a pas peur on sait où on va et
on a confiance en tout le monde
seul point noir de cette compétition
l'absence de médaille chez les dames le
vélodrome de saint quentin voilà qui
sera pas construire si jamais paris
obtient des jeux olympiques pour 2024 je
crois que la décision soit en 2017
maintenant tout le monde a l'air
d'accord pendant longtemps anne hidalgo
avait les rapports et y saute à l'eau à
l'air de monaco pour une candidature de
paris
qu'est ce que vous en pensez les uns et
les autres antonin oui alors un bon
rapport aux jeux olympiques je trouve
que il faudrait y réfléchir à deux ou
trois fois avant d'accepter même de la
turne on a vu ce que ça a donné
d'un port par exemple en angleterre la
dernière fois le comité olympique à
privatiser tout l'espace a organisé tout
comme comme il fallait organiser pour
que le business des marques les cours
par contre les citoyens n'ont pas eu
leur mot à dire là dessus et il ya une
perte de souveraineté évidente
moi je pense que ce référendum une
consultation populaire
je pense qu'il faudrait que ce soit le
les forces publiques qui organisent
l'espace et palais est pas le privé
alors au risque de creuser au contraire
le déficit public plutôt que deviendra
effectivement c'est ce qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs en grèce avec avec les jeux
olympiques qui ont eu lieu alors c'était
passé la fois précédente mais la fois
d'avant on a vu dans quel état sa
participé à mettre le pays à grasse
notamment c'était bonne gestion que ça
va maintenant je pensais qu'on parlait
des jeux olympiques il ya deux mille ans
effectivement il ya deux mille ans le
déficit est resté très fort mais n'ont
de toute façon il faut toujours
réfléchir à deux fois avant ce genre de
non c'est vrai que si on regarde si on
regarde quand même ce qui s'est passé un
peu partout aucune ville ne s'en des
remises les choses sont classés un point
depuis ben là c'est pas content du tout
enfin la puce pour un pays c'est enfin
jacques humain extraordinaire donc après
on va dire je vois pas je veux parce que
ça peut faire que de la sphère privée se
se sont gages au contraire très
certainement un vélo ça donne de
l'argent ça fait que ça fait tourner la
machine ça n'enlève rien aux
performances des sportifs une véritable
adhésion populaire quel que soit
l'endroit où ça se passe même à sotchi
où effectivement on pouvait émettre des
réserves sur le le site la façon dont
s'était construit la france a été fait
mais ça c'est les réserves qu'on peut
faire sur tout ce que ce que entreprend
ou ce qu'a entrepris poutine mais sinon
vrai que général jeux olympiques
franchement c'est une chose merveilleuse
et pour une fois que les gens se
réunissent pour autre chose que pour se
taper dessus pour faire des compétitions
ça très bien je vois même pas de raison
de râler contre ça quand on le conçoit
pas bloqué mais le coup de coude et
digérer jeudi
en l'occurrence justement je crois que
londres a servi d'exemple pour tout le
monde anne hidalgo qui était prudente et
à ce titre on peut justement s'y pencher
avec plus de bienveillance et qu'elle a
très bien expliqué qu'elle voulait un
budget qui soit modéré qu'on en est à 4
milliards c'est quelque chose comme ça
et que les 6 ou prendrait 1,2 milliard
un milliard huit à son compte qu'elle
engageait les entreprises à participer
également auteur de deux milliards et
donc que la dépense serait modérée alors
nécessairement ce sera toujours plus
mais comme disait jean charles sa forme
toujours une forme de liesse populaire
c'est quand même un élément rassembleur
et fédérateur qui l'un dans l'autre s'il
est réfléchie et bien pensé peut-être
très positif c'est lente accélérateur
pour le projet du grand paris
parce qu'en réalité notre capital
aujourd'hui est enfermé dans des
frontières trop étroites et il est clair
que le projet des jeux olympiques
permettrait à la ville de paris de
pouvoir adhérer à ce grand projet quel
grand paris c'est pas mal j'adhère
évidemment au fait que nous avons besoin
et surtout en ce moment d'une société
difficile d'avoir des grands projets qui
nous rassemble c'est le cas pour ces
grands événements que sont les
événements sportifs et notamment les
jeux olympiques c'est aussi le cas pour
des grands monuments c'est aussi le cas
pour des grandes idées ou des grands
hommes
et nous avons besoin de ça quand on voit
justement les grands projets inutiles
qui ont été construits à sao paulo ou à
sotchi sotchi maintenant c'est
complètement en ruines seville ouais
c'est vide ses origines s'étaient
construits sur des espaces naturels qui
ont été détruits voilà qu'est ce qui
s'est passé
excusez moi mais on a quand même on a
quand même déjà un vélodrome
à paris on a reconstruit un à saint
quentin
j'ai maintenant il est grand temps que
le vel d'hiv lui la tâche au vélodrome
attend bombay en tout cas en tout cas on
a en tout cas on tout en ironie que
maintenant de 13,6 me suis bien moi
j'aimais bien me promener parmi les
chênes centenaires et des tripes et des
grenouilles l'avoir montré aujourd'hui
le vélodrome
et quand on voit le nombre de bâtiments
vides qui se vident à saint quentin en
yvelines
je penserai l'ancien bricorama ou même
au ski ouest où il ya plus que 10% de
magasins tout est complètement vide
moi je me dis que les grands projets ça
un peu du passé quoi faudrait regarder
aujourd'hui ce qu'on a vraiment besoin
et arrêter de se lancer dans des projets
déposés déficit vous perdez le sens du
peuple parce que très honnêtement que
vous êtes censés défendre parce que le
vélo c'est bien un sport populaire et
nièces populaire et là je mange et je
suis allé et vous visiblement non aux
championnats du monde c'était
extraordinaire je dire les gens étaient
ravis d'y aller il y aller en famille ce
n'était pas le grand prix de diane avait
pas de chapeau il y avait pas de traiter
pas l'événement mondain peut-être les
casquettes mais c'est fait magnifique et
les gens adorent le vélo donc vélo moi
le message henry tous les jours j'en
fais tous les jours c'est moyen vraiment
moyen de transport non mais il faudra
regarder des gens de tourner en rond sur
une piste pour moi c'est juste un succès
mais pas le sport si vous trouvez ça
c'est autour de ryad et on peut se
servir de v le coffre d'outils pratiques
on peut en faire du sport les structures
publiques ce qui est le cas pour une
structure sportive
là tu parles et skywest comme tu parles
de bricorama on est vraiment sûr de la
structure privée pourquoi est-ce-que
skywest janvier rien c'est parce qu'il
ya des procès par rapport à la
concurrence des boutiques et intérêts on
est quand même dans un autre domaine est
la vôtre aux fondamentaux c'est du
partenariat public privé ont fait
construire des trucs inutiles parce que
ça s'appelait aux industriels et que les
politiques anti wrangler fédéral parce
qu'elle fait en plus d'argent
l'argent il ya strictement aucun rapport
entre bricorama et pedro qu'un jeu
diront peut être d'une mauvaise foi
absolue on en trouvera jamais eu aucun
des bâtiments des manises more a man a
là aucun des bâtiments qui vivotent non
l'argument quand même c'est vrai que je
lis l'australien perdu 2 milliards il ya
des villes qui ont mis trente ans à
rembourser les dettes qu'elles ont dû
faire pour pour organiser les jeux
olympiques c'est ça le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on est en effet dans une
société où l'argent ne coule plus à
flots qu'il faut en effet que ça
nécessite même si ça vous fait de la
peine
un partenariat public privé pour
organiser des choses comme ça il faut en
effet que les entreprises investissent
c'est pas sûr qu'elles le fassent ça
peut ça peut être bien gérée
intelligemment géré surveiller il faut
que les coûts soient pas énorme livrer
les 30 milliards en effet de pékin on
n'y arrivera pas ensuite
arrêtons de reprocher à toute tentative
d'organiser un petit peu le sport à
grande échelle et le sport vraiment
populaire et de l'accabler de tous les
maux parce que on a construit à paris la
philharmonie mc2 dans l'est de paris le
budget est multiplié par trois et même
pas fini l'architecte fait un procès
hélas comme c'est 100% culturel
j'appelle on entend beaucoup moins de
gens râler mais je veux dire c'est pas
plus choquant dit moins choquant qu'un
cadeau drogba est en déficit
je rappelle que la casse qui a redonné
le vélodrome d'un budget parce que sinon
ils fonctionneraient plus à l'heure où
on parle mais la tour eiffel a été
longtemps aussi et puis je comprends
l'opéra allemand là c'est pareil alors
c'est pas ses mots elle fut décrié et
c'était un analyse construite comme la
même faille est heureusement que l'état
doit subventionner des choses on
subventionne le père a win the scene
solidarité c'est très bien en
subventionner le saint quentin c'est
très bien subventionné les théâtres
s'est très bien intégré le groupe avait
pas de raison que ça vachement pour
revenir sur les jeux olympiques
comptablement je crois pas qu'ils aient
un pays qui a équilibré ses comptes sur
une opération que marina comptablement
simplement gallen les nations du réseau
de la nation les nations font parler
d'eux et réhabilité en revanche ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'elles font de la
compétition entre les nations se bat
tout pour essayer les jeux olympiques
chez elles ou peut-être se poser la
question de savoir si la rentabilité
n'est pas effective de rentabilité à
court terme
comptable mais une rentabilité à long
terme et surtout d'image d'image voilà
formant de la commune quand on sait que
le foot par exemple 2016 par exemple
peut-être organisé dans le désert on
peut se poser la question de savoir
combien de praticiens de football vont
ils jouer après donc il ya vraiment le
souci est le désir d'une comme l'action
on sera d'accord
en même temps je pense que les nations
ont besoin toutes les nations les
peuples surtout ont besoin de se
projeter et si ça sert pas ça va être
calme aujourd'hui ça de toute façon il y
aura une utilité il faut que ça une
utilité si vous avez des chiffres
justement concernant le football et
l'organisation de la coupe du monde je
crois que quand c'était en 98 enfants
c'était moins d'un milliard ça sera 200
milliards au qatar vont mettre la glace
vous mettez la au racing c'est vrai
qu'il ya peut-être des à peut-être aussi
de faire garder raison
c'est à dire de ne pas dépenser non plus
des sommes folles dont on sait qu'elles
ne seront jamais remboursés en même
temps si le cas pas envie d'aller
plonger le qatar les moyens de faire
face à catane fallu la consommation
énergétique est phénoménal
la consommation de pétrole sera aussi
tous les matins si il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire peut-être que vous dans
votre quotidien vous allez bien non mais
vous pourrez le qatar auraient le droit
de rien faire
paul erding était déjà interdit de
football où natalie thoumas on peut très
bien les entrées décentraliser les
compétitions faire des compétitions
locales jeudi revient pas forcément
besoin de son talent il a exactement
l'image alors est-ce qu'il vaut mieux
les jeux olympiques où l'exposition
universelle puisque ça va se jouer entre
les deux candidatures les deux noms les
deux ou trois contacts ne vend pas les
deux je trouvais pas tranché je crois
que les youth qu'on pût rassembleur
c'est plus populaires aussi voire plus
rentable très bien peut-être un autre
notre sujet
la polémique déchaînée par les propos de
roger qu carbone le président du crif
qui a déclaré marine le pen est
irréprochable en matière d'antisémitisme
pas forcément tout le front national
mais enfin l'antisémitisme il est dû
principalement à quelques musulmans il a
pas
il n'a pas il n'a pas montré du doigt
tous les musulmans mais quelques
musulmans
évidemment les propos ont fait scandale
qu'est ce que vous en pensez mais ça va
parce que nous avons le premier je
pensais que c'était plutôt le citizen
mustapha qu'on avait invité mais
finalement c'est à moi que revient cette
charge de répondre d'abord d'abord la
première la première chose c'est que moi
ça me gêne qu'on tout de suite on saute
sur les propos d'un homme qui l'aurait
eu probablement qui dépassent sa pensée
ou qui étaient pas d'une grande
précision
ça reste quelqu'un que je que je connais
pour le coup que je suis et sur lequel
on peut pas lui reprocher d'avoir voulu
prémédité ce type 2 on va dire de de
propos polémiques çà c'est la première
chose
la seconde chose qu'est ce qu'il dit est
dit finalement marine le pen a une
stratégie
et qui est globalement la bonne
puisqu'il dit lui même
elle est insoupçonnable non finalement
il valide et avec elle à pabu stratego
elle même ouvert le front national il va
être pas pour autant ce que fait le
front national ce que propose le front
national simplement il valide une
stratégie claire et pour le coup il a
pas tort sauf que tout le monde doit
bien décrypté ça veut dire ça veut dire
elle ne dit pas ça simplement il y en a
beaucoup d'autres qui le disent pour
elle donc je pense que dans sa façon de
formuler les choses il ya c'est vrai
mais en même temps ça laisse à supposer
et ses anneaux éventuellement le
commenter voire lui-même de rectifier
ensuite sur les musulmans responsable
c'est à dire les gens qui ont commis des
actes et qu'on a qualifié qu'on a
rapproché de la communauté musulmane
si tenté qui est une communauté en
l'occurrence oui de la même façon c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué de dire qu'il
n'est pas musulman si les musulmans on
l'a présenté comme étant comme tel de la
même façon il a dit les choses comme
elles sont donc moi je suis pas du tout
choqué par ce qu'il a dit c'est plus ce
qu'on a voulu lui faire dire qui me gêne
et la manière dont on s'est accroché
finalement à lire entre les lignes
pas du tout choquée en revanche en
revanche ça nécessite d'être précisé
et il l'a fait lui-même ses voiliers
caricaturer ses propos là il faut faire
très très attention moi je l'écouté en
direct streaming j'ai pas été choqué que
mustapha de ce qu'il a dit c'est le
radis tous les musulmans dans quelques
dans la façon dont il l'a dit et ce
qu'il a dit était pas choquant ensuite
évidemment c'est très vite caricaturer
parce que on a besoin de faire du mal
aux options d'événements concret ou
qu'on essaye en avril pour dire les
choses
voilà donc là aux hommes est précisément
le politiquement correct est encore plus
dangereux que ce qu'a dit ce que c'est
cette personnalité par contre je trouve
que il faut arrêter d'exacerber en
permanence des contacts les dialogues
parlant de la religion aux places stop
stop et ça ça devient dangereux
non mais simplement dire voilà le le
supermarché cacher ses traits au nom il
l'a été et un gain dépend de ce qu'il a
dit il y avait des choses bien plus
importantes que ça sur la tolérance et
d'ouverture d'esprit
avis il aurait fallu insister sur ce
sujet là malheureusement la presse s'est
emparée des deux ou trois phrases qui
pouvaient poser polémique pour en faire
du buzz c'est la grande mode aujourd'hui
on en est encore une fois dans
l'immédiat tout et pour tout et ça c'est
très très dangereux maintenant
honnêtement cet homme que mustapha
connais moi je le connais pas mais je
les écoutais en direct très honnêtement
a eu un comportement parfaitement ouvert
et tolérant
ce qu'il a dit mais finalement il a mis
le doigt sur des choses qui paraissent
peut-être pas politiquement correct mais
il a juste appuyé sur des phénomènes je
dirais deux tendances lourdes sur
lesquels ils laissaient d'interpeller la
société c'est une bonne chose je trouve
que des personnalités en vue de ce
niveau interpelle la société juste un
mot
probablement que boubekeur serait venu à
cette soirée si la polémique n'avait pas
enflé auquel cas il s'est senti obligé
de dire oui bah à mon avis toute la
communauté musulmane s'est senti choqué
par ce qu'il a dit parce qu'on l'a fait
prétendre aux qualités ici n'est pas
présentés non plus ce qui a donné un
effet une seule et même de l'autre
réforme aussi de sephora moi j'ai pas
entendu de propos de cure man maintenant
ah bon j'aimerais quand même souligner
plusieurs choses à l'époque de dreyfus
l'antisémitisme n'était pas le propre
des musulmans ils s'étaient pas elle qui
était en cause
je pense vraiment que c'est justement ça
le problème ne serait ce que c'est le
même antisémitisme est que le début du
siècle
ben écoute et lentilles oui moi je
connais pas mal de musulmans qui ont des
propos très tolérant très ouvert et très
respectueux parce que en terme de
religion ils sont pas si éloignés que ça
notamment à copenhague il ya eu une
ronde qui a été formé après les
attentats tragiques de juifs et de
musulmans
donc je pense que de nos jours il n'ya
pas il ya certainement certains
musulmans qui font preuve
d'antisémitisme mais pas qu'eux donc
c'était un peu facile de mettre encore
en lumière cette facette lecture on va
dire de la situation et
et puis de la même façon tout à l'heure
vous parliez de coulibaly qui a voulu
faire son mener son action dans cet
hiver cacher coulibaly il n'est pas
reconnu comme étant musulman par les
musulmans je pense que c'est très
important de le souligner le fait au nom
alors voilà voilà voilà c'est ça mais je
pense qu'en fait les vrais monsieur je
pense que cette attention à cet argument
parce que si vous dites que koulibaly
est pas reconnu comme un musulman par
les musulmans ça veut dire que les deux
autres en revanche sont reconnus comme
étant des terrains dangereux
oui c'est à dire mais je disais bon
musulman le propre des religieux des
vrais religieux c'est ce que tous quels
que soient leurs cultes ont tendance à
dire c'est la tolérance de l'autre le
respect de l'autre oui mais ce qui nous
intéresse un peu c'est les gens qui
dérapent parce que sinon effectivement
tout le monde personne n'ira dire que la
majorité des musulmans sont antisémites
et c et sont eux sont violents personne
ne niera dire ça donc ce qui est
intéressant ce qui fait débat c'est une
minorité de gens qui déconne donc c'est
là qu'on s'intéresse à que des musulmans
qui dérape méliand d'arthrite et qui
décode de la partout et malheureusement
le racisme y en a aussi partout et dans
les temps tous les sens
donc il faut y faire très très attention
donc il faut vraiment essayer je crois
que nous devons peut-être y contribuer
et de faire en sorte que les aspects
religieux reste dans l'intimé le
personnel ça doit rester discret moi
pour ma part une grande tolérance suis
chrétien je considère qu'on doit
respecter ma religion
au même titre que je respecte les autres
religions moi j'accepterai qui a un
minaret dans mon quartier si tous les
pays musulmans sans exception accepter
qu'il y ait une église dans les leurs et
qu'il respectait les chrétiens comme
nous respectons les musulmans les juifs
les bouddhistes et toutes les autres
religions mais je pense qu'il faut
maintenant essayer de calmer le jeu en
en parlant moi parlons plus des jeux
olympiques et simplement de la religion
je vous rejoins cerner ce qu'est ce qui
vous regarde et un sujet sur une femme
de guyancourt qui est 32 ans qui est
parti avec son fils rejoindre la syrie
vous en connaissez peut-être aussi à
trappes
non non mais regardez on en reparle
juste après et puis on parlera aussi de
françois hollande et des français de
souche c'est l'étonnement et
l'incompréhension qui règne en mairie de
montigné ce mercredi quand les agents
des couches chez nos confrères du
parisien
un article signalant qu'une animatrice
de la maison de quartier andré malraux
situé dans le quartier des prés se
répartit faire le djihad en syrie la
jeune femme de 32 ans était employé en
qualité d'animatrice famille elle avait
donné sa démission et quitter son poste
jeudi dernier c'est samedi qu'elle
aurait rejoint la turquie avec son fils
de quatre ans en mairie on précise que
l'équipe de la maison de quartier a été
abasourdi par la nouvelle
elle ne montrait aucun signe de
radicalisation dit dans ses propos qui
était cohérente dans ses vêtements
la semaine dernière elle a encore
assisté à une réunion d'équipé et tout
s'est très bien passé explique-t-on en
mairie la municipalité précise
travailler de concert avec l'association
dire afin de mener un travail de
sensibilisation auprès des jeunes de la
ville
la mairie a aussi demandé à
l'association des musulmans de monty
n'est de faire preuve de vigilance
du côté de la mairie de guyancourt où
résidait cette jeune femme et sa famille
aucun commentaire à apporter
la mairie dit avoir découvert la sphère
dans les colonnes de nos confrères du
parisien
voilà donc oui c'est vrai que ça existe
ça vous avez vu un cas comme ça même
dans le même journal on a fait part
d'une famille ou de gens qui sont partis
en syrie pour la trappe en l'occurrence
dans le nouvel obs
c'est pas compliqué
on a eu ce reportage en immersion pour
le club et puis on a eu cet incident est
effectivement une dame qui est venu
mercredi après-midi chercher son fils et
sa et donc elle est venue au club de
foot parce que son fils avait dit qu'il
était parti en tournoi de foot donc un
art vivant tous les arguments pour dire
qu'il était qui serait pas là
effectivement on s'est aperçu ensuite
qu'il était parti probablement
probablement cela étant c'est n'y avait
pas forcément ému en cours ou attrape on
en entend bien repartir à la hausse
envisagée en bretagne dans la nièvre
parce que ce que je trouve intéressant
dont on parle pas encore beaucoup celle
inverse
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui
partent pour lutter contre nice il ya
notamment un anglais il ya non seulement
que nous sa propriété il a réalisé toute
sa fortune pour partir combattre et dit
je ne reviendrai que quand on aura eu la
peau de pêche
il yad'autres d'autres européens qui
partait schultz et s'éteint un truc
assez intéressant aussi parce que c'est
une sorte de brigades internationales
nous publions donc ouais c'est agace ça
s'est passé au 12e siècle déjà et des
nobles avait fait comme ça dont de leur
fortune et de leur personne ça
s'appelait les templiers
on a besoin de lancer et vous en êtes
l'heureux héritiers de dire un pas de
leur fortune sans que ça serait un mot
sur le sur eux sur le bout justement de
françois hollande qui répondait
justement roger cukierman dans dix ans
mais il ya aussi des français de souche
il voulait il voulait faire allusion des
effets assez c'est au fond qui ont qui
sont eux qui ont détruit ce cimetière
juif enfin je pense que c'était à ce qui
le faisait allusion est ce que est ce
que dans sa bouche je pense que c'était
de d'ailleurs d'abord deuxième degré il
avec nos pays ces expressions
mais est ce que cette expression est
aussi choquant du neuf on a bien voulu
dire c'est tout ça n'a strictement rien
de choquant surtout dans la dans la
bouche de françois hollande parce qu'on
peut reprocher sûrement beaucoup de
choses à françois hollande
mais c'est pas sur ce terrain là qu'on
peut le composent chercher
dû chercher des noises ensuite la partie
moment il ya beaucoup de gens et
probablement à juste titre qu'ils
revendiquent une une filiation des
origines qui ne sont pas de souche ne
pas pourquoi on pourrait pas aussi de
l'autre côté dire qui a défoncé de
sousse qui veut pas dire que les
français qui ne sont pas formés hier
quand même ne sont pas de souche serait
meilleur respectives mais c'est une
distinction qui n'a rien de choquant
encore une fois on peut de temps en
temps appeler un chat un chat sont sauf
que envie de chaalis deux rivaux directs
a au coeur français de souche quoi parce
que l'on est on a un pays d'émigration
absolue la politique
être français c'est un droit politique
c'est pas un droit du sang sanary
n'avait depuis des fous on sait très
bien ce que ça veut dire quoi qu'ils
utilisent le plus les gros les petits
pots etc
valverde suivre aussi les rations sujet
est maintenant shaq pour estimer parce
qu'elle mérite vraiment ce cas le maire
mais c'est vrai que alors au delà de ça
au delà de ce débat c'est vrai qu'on a
l'impression d'être dans une société où
on ne peut plus rien dire rien c'était
tout de suite à procès un procès
d'intention parfois un procès publicis
est très tendue c'est très dangereux je
ferais la même réflexion que pour le
nôtre ami présent du crif kocaman de
même façon on sait de la même façon
comme la grippe sa grille peu aux uns et
aux autres et jean louis se sont
agrippés à cette histoire
de la même façon on est resté sur un mot
bon en même temps il est vrai qu'on
utilise quasiment tous là on sait plus
quoi dire les français les français d un
soussou des français c'est à dire tu
vois ce que je veux dire
car udinese prenant l'unacois donc à mon
avis faut peut-être nous donner un petit
coup de main pour qu'on se comprenne
sans qu'il s'en veulent forcer son
sommet donc c'était moi de temps en
temps ça même de dire tu vois ce que je
veux dire
il est blond encore plus que d'un simple
coup de le reprendre le propos n'est
drôle ont gêné de scènes nationales
illusion à ce que dit le front national
lorsqu'en plus ce feuilleton sciemment
jeu c'est vrai c'est vrai tu as raison
on parlait de la grippe tout à l'heure
et des virus
c'est vrai que la notion de souche est
un peu compliqué bien sûr est repartie
aux souches à partir de quand elle est
avec à elle la première technologique a
donné qu a donné naissance à toutes ses
formes ce qui nous pose problème
personnellement c'est que on est un
besoin justement de dire qu'il ya
plusieurs froid c'est différent de créer
une sorte de hiérarchie entre les
français alors qu on est tous français
ce qu'on écarte ce que voyager parce
qu'on l'aurait menacé le dre pour doha
les camions s'est pointé du doigt
quelques bulles
il voulait dire aussi qu'il y avait des
bons normande et lâche un des des
enfants qui détenait en france qui
étaient nés de parents français qui
aussi se donner à des actes antisémites
voilà je crois que c'est juste ça qu'il
a voulu dire par exemple quand mustapha
ne fait pas mystère de ses origines
algériennes mercredi à ccc dis moi c'est
non on peut connaître une nouvelle
afrique ministère aussi de réussite
république justement mais je trouve ça
très bien il n'y a rien de bien
évidemment de honteux à dire qu'on a des
origines algériennes deux dans le même
cas pourquoi est ce que ce serait
honteux de dire qu'on a des origines
poitevine houle orange et dire voilà
donc il ya une sorte de stigmatisation
de quelqu'un qui dira ah bah oui hélas
je ne ne vient que de de la france
métropolitaine bah oui ça peut arriver
et c'est pas une tare donc c'est pas une
tare de venir en algérie ce n'est pas
une tare devenir du poitou voilà si on
pouvait juste être d'accord là dessus on
arrêterait le dire sans arrêt comme un
étendard d'où on vient ce qu'on fait non
juste effectivement la solution pour une
fois en plein gré ce serait juste
suffisante mais ne tarde pas à voir sans
arrêt cet étendard là derrière soi c'est
pas forcément utile je sais déjà contre
distance non mais c'est bien en plus une
en france mais bon de temps en temps on
a besoin aussi de nommer les choses on
parle pas forcément de commande
politique tout le temps mais il ya aussi
la religion a parlé tout à l'heure il ya
la culture
il ya des sensibilités
je me définis comme un français un
citoyen puisque c'est même écrit dans le
jeu refait une pub pour le journal
citizen nahr ben oui mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya des sensibilités et cette
sensibilité moi je la revendique
on peut en parler aussi il n'y a rien
d'exceptionnel à dire par exemple que
l'humour quand je quand je m'exprime
dans la langue arabe pour être né en
france et maîtrisé à peu près le
français je maîtrise tout autant là il
m'arrive d'en parler en arabe parce que
j'ai une sensibilité pour un certain
humour par exemple pour battre temps en
temps on dit fait partie des beurs je ne
suis pas choqué mais c'est vrai que le
beurre peut avoir une connotation qui
est celle de oui mais bear c'est du
verlan du verlan le ramène à la cité et
donc va nous ramener à des voiles à san
siro et ça c'est à la fois probablement
un peu choquant pour certains mais je
suis très détendu et que cette histoire
je je je je recommande un film que tout
le monde devrait regarder c'est laid ni
les la vie de lenny bruce qui est
jouée admirablement par dustin hoffman
et il ya un passage dans le film un film
des années 70 75 il ya un passage là
dessus ou effectivement à un moment
donné dans son spectacle s'arrête et il
interpelle tout le monde sait ce qui est
dit est ce qu'il ya des ue pendant la
femme ce qui est des blacks skis à dire
ce qui est c'est vrai que c'est très
américain
décomplexés ce sujet il on parle avec
beaucoup mais ça vous avez sur le tarif
sur google ils reconnaissent ils
reconnaissent les communautés c'est un
communautarisme
oui qu'est ce que j'espère on verra
jamais en france non mais justement
c'est une façon de conserver la société
justement il se moque de savoir qui est
juive où il réside il faisait la pièce
manioc on en parle mieux à propos de
communautarisme l'idée saugrenue de
décaler maintenant les fêtes religieuses
et fait créé très intéressant
énorme
une aberration à se taper la tête contre
les murs déjà le fait que le diront noël
ou à pâques mais fait divers fête du
printemps
excellent parce que aujourd'hui on est
aussi dans une période où le climat est
déréglée et le fait de fêter une les
saisons ces mots ça montre notre
attachement climat et je trouve que deux
on peut faire les deux mais ce que je
veux dire c'est quelque chose mais ça va
beaucoup plus loin mais on peut dire ça
c'est pas mal fait et le climat qu'on
change je ne sais pas ce qu'on veut
éviter justement de donner c'est la
référence chrétienne de l'importance
dans ce cas très importante à une
religion qui est en effet très laïque je
le sais ce très grave denis roy
respecter tout le monde et que tout le
monde finalement on se sente bien dansé
dansé dans ses racines dans ses cultures
danser ses origines est plutôt baissier
to go mais c'est au contraire de laisser
la place à douze mois il faut donner un
jour je donnais des conseils sur les
esquifs ont donné des jours de congés
pour qui pourrait ce qu'il faut donner
le problème se pose
jusqu'à présent personne et est empêché
de fêter s'est faite là il suffit de
prendre un jour de congé de façon ferme
et des hommes et des faits très plus de
fonds il ya là où la forêt inchangé vous
voulez palier des origines historiques
de la tâche facile à prendre mais c'est
peut-être vous avez vous pas les miennes
française et ce combo alors on l'a fait
de la grille ça dure six mois et en
français vous avez d'un pays dont les
grillages génisson judéo-chrétienne
historique pouvez pas le nier c'est donc
vous avez 10 avait dit quoi on est des
joueurs en france républicaine danger il
a mérité vous avez mal vous ils disent
vous fait un constat historique sur la
wii voilà aujourd'hui quelle est la
réalité c'est à dire
la population et des religions échanges
en france c'est pas parce qu'à un moment
donné il ya eu il ya eu des racines
qu'il faut qu on en reste aux racines la
république c'est aussi un projet
collectif c'est le commun et le comment
ils changent en fonction des gens qui
peuplent ce comment je suis assez
d'accord avec antonin je pense qu'en
fait les génération de mes parents par
exemple
bon elles sont peut-être encore plus l
art h et même si elle s'en défend tu as
une culture du colonialisme et moi je
pense faire partie des français dits de
souche mais je pense qu'effectivement il
faut s'ouvrir si on veut aller vers un
monde meilleur si on veut aller vers un
monde plus tolérant il faut intégrer les
gens qu'on a nous mêmes invités si on
parle de l'immigration par rapport
lorsqu'on leur a demandé de venir dans
les années 70 parce qu'on en avait
besoin aujourd'hui pour qu'il se sent
bien et pour qu'on vive tous enfin parce
que on était les demandeurs à la base il
faut s'ouvrir et si on a décidé en 1905
de séparer l'église et l'état me
semble-t-il écoles et les publics n donc
rattachée à l'état non à l'église et je
pense que c'est pas plus mal pour que
chacun trouve sa place de façon plus
apaisée de rebaptiser les vacances comme
ça vaille alors noël n'est plus
simplement une fête religieuse c'est
aussi un moment où on achète beaucoup de
cadeaux ou pas qu'elle fasse appel de la
france pas seulement à lui encore pire
c'est une fête commerciale
oui d'accord enfin voila c'est encore
pire mais s'est laissé sa pièce est
simple côté républicain des choses c'est
plus du type plus seulement une fête
religieuse c'est une fête religieuse
pour ceux qui sont pour les croyants
pour ceux qui sont pratiquants mais pas
pour les sauver coca cola n'est pas
républicain c'est-à-dire que l'on me
wade a été popularisé par marie
khadraoui non mais moi ça le père noël
rouge c'est coca cola qui losc il faut
aller au bout de ce principe alors
sephora c'est ce que vous dites ou faut
il faudrait aller au bout de ce principe
c'est à dire faire des jours fériés
selon les religions de chacun je pense
que la religion doit rester en dehors de
l'école l'école est la république c'est
à dire qu' il n'y a pas de jours fériés
les gens qui ne veulent pas aller en
classe pour fêter leur fait qu'ils le
fassent qu'ils en prennent la
responsabilité et il n'y a aucun souci
quatre jours fériés met bas sont laïcisé
complètement en étant complètement
honnête l'école oui je pense que ce
serait fait fait de vacances d'hiver
vacances de noël je pense que ce serait
plus porteur et que ça pas suffire et
les relations et chacun se sente il peut
intégrer dans les écoles primaires
justement de parler des français dit
tout qu'est-ce qui se disent les enfants
ben l'enfant qui va être par exemple
blanc qui peut avoir des parents qui ne
sont pas forcément très tolérant et très
ouvert j'y ai entendu moi je suis en
contact avec des enfants
qu'est ce qu'ils vont dire à un noir où
justement un français d'origine
maghrébine a nommé toi t'es pas français
ah non mais toi t'es qu'un sale noir
ces deux matches mais mais s'est
entretenu en fait je pense que c'est
tout un système qu'il faudrait parce que
justement si on lie 6 est complètement
cet espace républicain ça passif iraient
les relations chacun se sentirait plus
accepter et à force à long terme
les mentalités évoluent ray et les
mentalités deviendrait plus tolérante
c'est pas souvent pris 20 ans ici pour
faire un petit effort sera bien sûr que
tu as compris fait mondiaux cependant
ces arguments intelligent et patrice
poser la question de savoir si nous
accepterions qu'il y ait des fêtes
religieuses m que les fêtes chrétiennes
la réponse est de la part de nos jeunes
amis plutôt non restons laïque faisons
en sorte que des vacances sur les
vacances etc on les attache pas
automatiquement à une fête religieuse et
moi je préconise
effectivement la religion dans la
discrétion donc le fait que des vacances
de noël s'appelle vacances d'hiver et
que les vacances de pâques ça peut être
long de printemps ne me gêne absolument
pas très bien voilà qui est dit on va
donc tout le monde n'est pas d'accord
avec ça est ce que quelqu'un a été le
dernier charlie hebdo
non ça va pas la paix loeb le nouveau
j'arrive de c'est un événement
incroyable parce que bon vie million de
journaux vendus non millions mais henry
mais le privé parce que la semaine
dernière il restait encore plein dans
les kiosques la mine après je ne sais
pas comme il y avait vendu
il ya un essai de panurge est évident là
maintenant il ya deux millions cinq je
crois imprimés donc il ya surtout
visiblement par rapport à 10000 abonnés
au départ maintenant 250 milles
visiblement il ya quand même une prise
de conscience de la société française à
l'égard de la liberté d'expression bon
c'est plutôt pas mal
oui c'est un geste mais je crois que
c'est bien que nous soyons conscients de
la nécessité de soutenir la liberté
d'expression si ça passe par deux
millions et demi de ventes de charlie
hebdo va très bien vous connaissez dans
sur le sujet je parle tellement les
suiveurs mais par contre je me réjouis
que la société française est pris une
position favorable à la diversité
d'opinion est ce que le cd ce triomphe
janvier est ce qu'il n'est pas il n'a
pas duré trois jours
sinon je pense que l'événement
l'événement a marqué la société
française incontestablement on peut pas
dire que ça a duré trois jours que par
contre le profit qu en a tiré quelques
leaders politiques n'est pas duré très
longtemps ça c'est un fait c'est qu'à
regarder les sondages ils sont
significatifs
en même temps je pense que la société
française et la société d'ailleurs toute
entière ça s'est su dans le monde entier
a pris conscience de la nécessité de
défendre cette forme de liberté qu'est
la liberté d'expression un mauvaise
puisque vous avez la parole peut-être
sur la modernisation du dialogue social
voulu par manuel valls
écoute je bois du petit lait et en même
temps je suis extrêmement contrarié
je bois du petit lait parce qu'enfin on
considère la nécessité d'améliorer le
dialogue social
waouh ça veut dire quoi se dire qu'on
doit favoriser
on le sait la reconnaissance de vrais
groupes permettant aux salariés de
toutes les entreprises les toutes
petites comme les très grandes de
s'exprimer et d'être reconnus pas
seulement les fonctionnaires et pas
seulement les fonctionnaires en même
temps les corps intermédiaires bien sûr
pardon de 2,2 d'assister templiers
toujours les mêmes formules mais quand
même ça a son importance côté
entreprises ce qui est une loi qui va
être promulguée au 1er janvier 2017 qui
va vraiment asseoir la représentativité
des organisations patronales petites et
grandes
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on voit
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya un échec et
bien parce qu'on a mis en face le medef
avec la cgpme et l'upa mais qui ne sont
hélas skin audible
avec les grands syndicats salariés qui
on le sait ne représente en réalité que
les arrêts des grandes entreprises et de
la fonction des forces
ça a été un péché c'est normal
maintenant je pense que le gouvernement
est manuel vals serait inspiré d'aller
plus loin dans cette réforme de trouver
les moyens de faire en sorte que le
dialogue social puisse s'intégrer dans
les petites entreprises
alors pour ce qui nous concerne très
souvent nous disent on m'attendait le
dialogue social il existe tous les jours
chez nous moi je suis patron de mon
restaurant
tous les jours j'ai évidemment réunion
avec l'ensemble de mes collaborateurs et
nous parlons beaucoup ensemble
il n'y a pas de formaliser une
attraction mutation alors il en faut un
peu faut pas non plus que ce soient
l'invention de leur usine à gaz
ce serait terrible mais les seuils et
c'est dans le domaine du dialogue social
il faut casser les codes la
représentation aujourd'hui est archaïque
totalement dépassé nous avons des moyens
à notre disposition qui nous permette de
pouvoir communiquer très vite très
facilement et de façon profonde
il faut les utiliser alors comment est
ce qu'on peut mettre ça dans une loi ça
va être difficile mais en même temps il
faut je prône de nouveaux interlocuteurs
dans ces débats et peut-être que manuel
valls serait inspiré d'en trouver ce
pays un père un problème politique c'est
à dire est ce que manuel valls a encore
la majorité de sa politique alors bien
sûr vous avez vu que j'ai l'impression
qu'il est minoritaire
cependant je vous disais ya pas très
longtemps que emmanuel macron serait
vraiment un fusible pour l'instant je
trouve que les maquereaux retient il est
extrêmement résistant et on s'apercevra
d'ailleurs ça commence déjà
au fil du temps que ce qu'il préconisait
en termes de réforme va plus dans le bon
sens c'est encore très timide mais ça va
dans le bon sens espérons que nous
allons accélérer le mouvement et faire
en sorte que des réformes dans ce pays
soit des réformes profondes elles sont
absolument indispensables
hélas nous avons l'habitude pour ce qui
nous concerne de faire les réformes dans
les douleurs ou dans la violence on va
couper la tête du roi là on a vu que ça
ne marchait pas et donc face qu'il faut
casser les codes nous sommes promenés
dans une période nous allons pouvoir
casser les codes je parlais de renverser
la table casser les codes c'est bien
aussi mais en tous les cas je crois que
le dialogue social est indispensable
mais il faut l'intégrer dans toutes les
petites entreprises sans pour autant
passer dans l'est
structure d'aujourd'hui qui sont
archaïques dépassé non moi la grippe
éventuellement non j'en ai peut-être
pour finir qu'on parle de bernard tapie
vous savez que le la cour d'appel est
revenu sur l'arbitrage qui bute est
extrêmement favorable puisque il touche
et d y toucher une un pactole avec cet
arbitrage mais voilà il ya une interview
dans le point qui me semble intéressant
de tapie qui dit au fond une plusieurs
périodes les périodes on dit aux gens
allaient battez vous vous pouvez y
arriver vous pouvez réussir vous voyez
gagner évidemment de l'argent avec puis
il ya des périodes où on dit europe on
va on va éradiquer tout ce qui dépasse
et dévoila était donc que c'est en effet
ce qui aurait ici qu'il faut qu'il faut
montrer du doigt un qu'il faut peut-être
chasser et dit on est dans une période
comme ça qu'est ce que vous en pensez
c'est pas un argument qu'il est
totalement idiot je trouve franchement
il a pas tort qu'on se consume viennent
de dudu bernard tapie animateur sur tf1
qui faisait des émissions comme ailleurs
la crise réussir et c'est n'avait pas un
journal de gauche ou de droite pour dire
du mal de tapie c'était le même
personnage n'est pas devenu c'est notre
f&c c'était une autre activité 90 il ya
des moments où on glorifiait le fait de
monter une boîte de réussir de gagner un
peu d'argent
le discours officiel était pas essayer
lancez vous et puis ça va ça va marcher
et c'est merveilleux on vous apprend en
prime time que comme comment vous faire
un petit peu de un petit peu dessous
puis c'est vrai que maintenant c'est pas
du tout comment gérer une entreprise
voilà maintenant c'est une catastrophe
absolue et c'est vrai que tapie au delà
de ça il est aussi reste bien évidemment
responsable des malheurs qui lui arrive
mais on ne va pas rentrer dans les
détails de la mairie il a raison sur cet
aspect là c'est vrai qu'en france on
n'aime pas tellement les gagnants on
n'aime pas les gens qui réussissent
il ya toujours on n'aime pas là on
n'aime pas l'argent on est bien en avoir
mais faut pas le dire la bonne preuve
c'est que jamais personne ne dit combien
on est un des seuls pays du monde où on
peut pas dire combien on gagne quand on
pose la question à quelqu'un combien
tout cas les a mais on le dit ce soit un
animateur télé ville à la radio
systématiquement les journalistes
balance sur les hommes politiques qui
reçoivent sur les sommes dues et s'est
jamais l'homme politique ose dire
allez au type qui l'interviewé vous
gagnez combien affaires france inter la
5 et canal plus jamais jamais on n'ose
pas testé une sorte de tabou donc en ce
sens
tapie a tout à fait raison en même temps
je crois que la france et ça c'est très
typique adore brûler ses idoles vous
regardez dans l'histoire remonte déjà au
pinacle soit sportif ou politique
industrielle on les monte au pinacle et
puis ensuite on adore les brûler ça
c'est génétique temps de notre pays
par contre il ya quelque chose que tapie
a de particulier c'est que il a été une
idole il a été un grand industriel il a
été un excellent meneur de jeu dans le
football il l aurait un bon acteur est
bon on cherche à le brûler il a une
capacité de résilience absolument
incroyable et c'est ça quelque part que
les français aiment en lui parce que
vous avez vu que si on devait analyser
sa cote de popularité des autres accusés
j'avais otaries et il est extrêmement
combatif il n'est jamais plus combatif
que lorsqu'il est en situation de
victime
et ça le français adorent d'un côté on
aimerait bien de brûler petit une idole
et donc on la brûle et de l'autre côté
on trouve que le côté robin des bois du
bonhomme est plutôt attachant
donc non mais là tu lorsque l'interview
dans le passé c'est juste un délire de
persécution
deux des riches quoi fins et enfin j'ai
aujourd'hui quand on regarde une
explosion des inégalités tout simplement
ce que ce que dit tapie ne vérifient pas
les riches encore plus riches auquel
beaucoup de gens qui quittent la france
qui vont à l'étranger mais aux grandes
surfaces comme si ça leur plaît si ça
leur plaît plus d'être france acquis et
qui partent au fra démocratie ensemble
au manque de solidarité
moi effectivement si je vais payer isf
reversés à l'époque vu que maintenant ça
n'est plus qu'à 75% de ma fortune bon
choix malheureux c'est une évidence
pourquoi est-ce qu'on millions oui mais
pourquoi partager ce qui est à soi mais
dire quand même justement sa commande et
de l'individualisme et on a pas on a on
n'a pas envie d'être solidaire tout
simplement je pense que c'est surtout ça
et après on met on met beaucoup en
lumière ce cette espèce de culte de
l'échec il faudra montrer qu'on réussit
ou si tant est que ce soit le cas j'en
sais rien moi je le vois pas comme ça
mais en tout cas ça ce serait aussi
quelque chose à à démonter et à
reconstruire
l'instruction est importante faire des
études c'est bien parce que mine de rien
aussi deux jours en on considère qu'avec
le commerce qui prévaut dans les tudors
sert plus à rien la culture c'est has
been c'est pareil ça s'appelait alors
que c'est faux je me suis bien heureux
de voir
voilà j'ai envie qu'ils disaient que
pour qu'une démocratie et je m'en
souviendrai toute ma vie je pense pour
qu'il ne démocratie fonctionne il
fallait que la population soit instruite
et il faut être instruit il faut
chercher à réussir parce que sinon c'est
tout le système qui s'effondre
collective ça m'évoque cette histoire de
bernard tapie c'est jean façon que c'est
toute la france il se cherche on a
l'impression que c'est on sait pas si on
est on va partir sur un modèle pour le
dire on parlait des modèle
communautariste au contraire sur ce
modèle républicain
ensuite sur un modèle économique qui
serait plutôt capitaliste ou au
contraire un modèle plutôt socialiste ou
plutôt social démocrate etc cette
affaire-là me laisse à penser que c'est
toute la france ils se cherchent et il
sera probablement quand j'ai parlé de
victimes par rapport à son procès ou par
rapport à sa personne mais que ça peut
être une victime par rapport à toute la
société qui se cherche on est en train
de chercher un modèle et on l'a prouvé
lucerne
rapide derrière parce que mon idole qui
veut quitter la france ribéry mon maître
ah oui je veux lire à la nationalité
européenne pour le football c'est
probablement un événement simplement
pour quelqu'un qui maîtrise aussi bien
le français qui partent à la limite en
allemagne ça me choque pas simplement
pouvoir faire le monde vous savez qui
dit que son fils se moque de sa fille se
moque de lui quand il parle allemand
mais alors elle l'a jamais vraiment ces
gens voient la regarde et hop c'est
mustapha l'art bonne quatre parts dans
de nouvelles offres cette semaine merci
et merci à tous les sacs et a très vite